[Musique]
c'est devenu un rituel presque sacré
plusieurs fois par année et demie en
sabah se rend au tarama visiter les
siens
un voyage dans le temps un voyage dans
l'horreur le 15 avril 1994
ses parents et 5000 autres tutsi ont été
massacrés
ici tu es dans cette église avec des
grenades achevée à coups de machette
edmond lui a été frappé en pleine tête
mais il a survécu miraculeusement je ne
pourrai jamais oublier que peut-être il
y ait des noms et des visages mais les
cris et les pleurs jamais ça nous
revient parfois mémoire ou store ses
cris et ses pleurs je vais devoir dire
avec toute ma vie il y en ait l'église
est aujourd'hui un mémorial où reposent
ceux qui sont tombés victimes de la
folie meurtrière des génocidaires hutus
ce soir notre correspondant d'afrique
jean françois bélanger nous avions en
compte réellement pour un reportage
il ya quinze ans il n'était alors qu'un
adolescent edmond nyonsaba n'avait que 6
ans le 15 avril 1994
et pourtant il garde un souvenir très
claire du jour le plus sombre de son
existence marquée à vie dans sa chair et
dans son coeur beaucoup de temps depuis
s'est écoulé mais une chose n'a pas
changé
l'émission qu'edmond s'est fixé en tant
que rescapé a raconté
témoignez qu'aucun animal si j'ai
survécu c'est grâce à dieu mais survivre
c'est également une responsabilité il
faut dire une nouvelle génération ce qui
s'est passé si on ne veut pas voir
l'histoire se répéter mais a quand même
en tête du championnat
edmond a aujourd'hui 31 ans il s'est
marié il a eu des enfants
nine d'hôtes à l'ena tran et avoir une
famille c'était mon rêve c'était un but
pour moi quand tu as perdu ta famille il
est essentiel d'en fonder une autre
sa femme donata est elle aussi une
orpheline
une rescapée du génocide leurs enfants
jo est là et elliot sens pour une source
de réconfort et de fierté
une source d'espoir aussi bâtir avec eux
rwanda nouveau où les divisions
ethniques est la haine n'ont pas de
classe qui sont encore trop petit pour
comprendre mais quand ils vont grandir
on doit leur enseigner la vérité avant
le génocide
les enfants apprenaient à l'école qui
étaient autour ou tutsi
nos enfants doivent plutôt apprendre que
nous sommes tous seront ne raconte pas
l'histoire comment ils vont l'apprendre
ailleurs de la mauvaise façon
et cela peut créer des rancoeurs de la
haine mais il ne faut pas accabler les
enfants pour les péchés de leurs parents
le rwanda est aujourd'hui un pays très
jeune
60 % de la population a moins de 25 ans
et donc n'a pas connu génocide
transmettre la mémoire de cette tragédie
est donc devenue une priorité ici
ces étudiants visite pour la première
fois le mémorial de kigali où sont
inhumés 250 mille victimes du génocide
sous les lits s'ils ont tous entendu
parler des événements tragiques qui ont
déchiré le pays peut en saisir l'ampleur
réelle et encore moins les causes
profondes
la visite est riche en enseignements
intense aussi en émotions
les photos des disparus leurs restes ne
laisse personne indifférent delphine ou
mozart est encore sous le choc je ne
peux pas m'empêcher de penser à ses
enfants à ses bébés qui ont été tués
pendant le génocide
pourquoi est-ce qu'ils ont été tués il
ne connaissait même pas leur groupe
ethnique
ils étaient tous des enfants de dieu
pour leurs enseignants des visites comme
celles ci sont essentiels seule façon
pour les jeunes rendait d'apprendre à
tirer les leçons de leur histoire des
messageries caen va être notre objectif
est de permettre à la nouvelle
génération de développer son esprit
critique
parmi ces jeunes il y à des descendants
des bourreaux et des descendants des
victimes on les rassemble pour leur
montrer comment on peut vivre ensemble
en harmonie en monnaie mais un autre
retraité edmond lui se donne encore
quelques années avant de tout raconter à
sa fille avant de lui passer le relais
de l'histoire et d'ici là sa priorité et
lui donner la meilleure éducation
possible malgré ses faibles moyens de
lui donner surtout l'enfance heureuse et
insouciante qu'il n'a pas connue
[Musique]
mais